الى اوكرانيا الان فبعد الحديث كثيرا عن
بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد يبدو انه بدا
يتضح بمرور الوقت حيث لجات كياف الى تغيير
تكتكاتها العسكريه من داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الى شن هجمات متقطعه ومتفرقه
داخل العمق الروسي هجوم على
مايو الماضي تبعته هجمات بثمان مسيرات قبل
يومين داخل العاصمه موسكو هجوم لم تتنبه
لكن بالطبع اتهمت من لم تتبنه لكنها اتهمت
بالوقوف ورقه
[موسيقى]
اخر سلسله الهجمات الاوكرانيه اليوم كانت
داخل بالجروب جنوب غرب روسيا والتي تقع
على بعد اربعين كيلومترا من الحدود
الاوكرانيه الجيش الروسي اعلن انه تصدى
بسلاحه الجوي ومدفعيته لثلاث محاولات غزو
اوكرانيه في منطقه
معززتين بدبابات هذا الهجوم جاء بعد قصف
اوكراني مكثف في منطقتي شبيكينو وجريف
ادى لاصابات بحسب ما اوردته السلطات
المحليه في المقاطعه هذه التطورات ليست
الاولى حيث شهدت منطقه بالبرود الاسبوع
الماضي توغلا مسلحا من اوكرانيا سبب صدمه
في روسيا ومنذ ذلك الحين تتعرض المنطقه
المتاخمه لمنطقه
لقصف عنيف بقذائف الهاون والمدفعيه وهجمات
بالطائرات المسيره حسب السلطات المحليه ما
دفع السلطات الى اجلاء السكان من بعض
المناطق الخلوديه محضره من تدهور الوضع
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات